good morning John being awake is awful I
feel like a poopoo
goodbye lemmings miss you already know
taxi driver was very nice he nearly
killed us we almost died but we're alive
uh-huh it has got this sweet outdoor
lounge area at the airport about fun is
play you're all grace deck of walls I'm
like check me out I'm outside there's a
plane behind me you gotta find cooler
spots at airports they go this way
there's the control tower it's cool
apparently I've chip herd up a little
bit now that I found this amazing place
so I'm headed to Chicago for tour I just
went through security with $2,000 in $2
bills they didn't even ask if you're
coming to see us if you buy merch in
cash we'll be getting your change in two
dollar bills at least while supplies
last so available
aside from change is this new flash
drive thing that I made that has every
song I've ever recorded or released even
the terrible ones and some of the
various stuff that's an interesting idea
cuz CDs how do you even use those
anymore for people who aren't going to
be on tour though I also have something
to sell to you John and I have had this
argument about Batman and whether he's
worthwhile so the next week we have two
shirts available one from my perspective
that says we are all bad people and one
John is from your perspective it says
Batman's just a rich guy with an
affinity for bats so to find out which
side nerdfighteria is on we're selling
both of them and we're going to count
and see whether we are indeed all bad
people or you know which design people
liked better John congratulations on
your golden bucket of popcorn that's
weird could be that's just weird that's
weird and yes my butt is freezing this
is not a warm place for my butt to be
I'm not doing the rest of this video
because I want you to be entertained
it's just gonna be interesting facts
about marriage fact number one and two
people who played Ferris Bueller's
parents in Ferris Bueller's Day Off met
on set and they got married so they had
kids and they didn't in any of the verus
which is unacceptable that number two of
the 19 couples brought together by the
television show bachelor
none of them are still together which is
really I guess not a super surprise but
it is interesting number three during
the Crimean War
a British shipmate after being told to
hit the deck instead ran forward toward
a live shell with its fuse hissing and
threw it off the side of a British naval
vessel for this act of bravery his
captain promoted him to lieutenant on
the spot also recommended him for the
Victoria Cross and introduced him to his
daughter the two later married one act
of bravery turned out pretty well for
that guy thirty years after this
photograph was taken at Walt Disney
World this little girl and this row boy
got married they didn't even live in the
same country at the time not at the time
they got married at the time the picture
was taken begging of Disney the guy who
was for 36 years the voice of Mickey
Mouse was married to the woman who was
the voice of Minnie Mouse also weird
David Tennant got married to an actress
who played his daughter in Doctor Who
the weird part of this is that she was
the actual daughter of a man who played
the doctor in Doctor Who John there are
so many people in the world that weird
coincidences are bound to happen in fact
it has happened many times that
childhood pen pals have met later in
life and gone on to get married but what
is exceptionally weird is when those two
people are Carey Mulligan and the dude
from Mumford & Sons they were childhood
pen pals and then they both
independently became famous and then
they reconnected later in life and got
married the universe is weird people who
are coming to see me on tour I'm really
looking forward to it thank you it's
going to be a great show John we are all
bad people and I'll see you on Tuesday
I fell bad for the poor people cuz when
we gave them a tip they had to sing a
song oh hey there ha ha nautical hello
mrs. Wainwright it is a pleasure to meet
you thank you for taking this
opportunity I would really I think I'm
perfect for this position wiggle and
Butchie wiggle it yeah